Tengo muchas ganas de intentar probar que
raíz de 2 es irracional
y justo eso es lo que vamos a ver
en este video,
vamos a intentar
demostrar que raíz de 2 es irracional...
que raíz...
Oh, que fea raíz...
que raíz de 2 es irracional...
irracional...
Ahora, para ver que
raíz de 2 es irracional,
voy a utilizar la contradicción,
voy a demostrar que raíz de 2 es irracional
por el método de contradicción
y para esto lo que hay que hacer
es suponer justo lo contrario
y vas a ver que vamos a llegar a algo absurdo
a una contradicción,
así que bueno,
tras lo que voy es probar que raíz de 2 es racional...
déjame atraparlo con este color...
y lo voy a probar por contradicción..
por contradicción...
lo voy a poner aquí...
demostración...
demostración
por contradicción...
Ahora,
date cuenta de que si yo llego
a un  absurdo suponiendo lo contrario,
es decir que raíz de dos es racional,
entonces cuando llegue
a ese absurdo que estoy buscando,
en ese momento
estoy diciendo que raíz de 2
debería de ser irracional, que es justo lo
que nosotros queremos, ok.
Entonces, la idea de esto es suponer
que raíz de 2 es racional
y lo voy a poner aquí...
raíz de 2 es racional...
vamos a suponer que raíz de 2 es racional
y vamos a ver si llegamos a un absurdo
y si decimos
que raíz de 2 es racional,
entonces podemos decir...
entonces podemos decir que raíz de 2...
raíz de 2
lo puedo ver como una fracción,
como una razón entre 2 enteros.
Entonces, a raíz
de 2 lo voy a escribir
como a una división
entre dos números enteros,
"a"
entre...
voy a utilizar este color...
entre "b"...
entre "b", ok.
Ahora, lo importante
de todo esto es ver que "a" y "b",
es decir,
esta fracción que tengo aquí,
es una fracción irreducible
y eso es muy importante,
si esta fracción no fuera irreducible,
bueno pues entonces podemos sacar
algún factor común,
cancelarlo y tarde o temprano
llegara a una fracción irreducible,
todas las fracciones
después de reducirlas
llegan a ser una fracción irreducible
y eso es súper importante
para esta demostración,
que esta fracción es irreducible
o dicho de otra manera,
que "a" y "b" solo tienen
como factor común al 1,
lo que es exactamente lo mismo
que decir que "a" y "b" son co-primos
o primos relativos entre sí.
Ok, entonces yo lo que quiero ver,
o más bien, yo lo que voy a suponer es que esta
fracción es una fracción irreducible,
aquí está la clave de esta demostración...
irreducible.
Ok, voy a suponer
que esta fracción es irreducible
y si eso es cierto,
estoy diciendo que "a" y "b",
ok, "a" y "b"...
y "b"
son primos relativos
entre sí o son co-primos o podemos decir
que no tienen...
no
tienen...
no tienen
ningún factor común...
ningún...
factor
común...
común,
que no sea el 1, ¿no?
excepto el 1...
excepto el 1, ok.
Y esto es muy importante,
raíz de 2 lo vamos a ver
como una fracción irreducible,
todas las fracciones las podemos llevar
a una fracción irreducible
y eso quiere decir que tanto "a" como "b",
no tienen ningún factor común,
excepto el 1...
excepto el 1.
Ok, ahora,
utilizando esta misma información
manipulemos
justo esto que tenemos aquí,
si esto es cierto,
eso quiere decir que raíz de 2...
lo voy a poner así,
raíz de 2 es lo mismo
que "a" entre "b"...
entre "b", ok.
¿Y de aquí qué te parece si elevo al cuadrado
ambos lados de esta igualdad?
Llegaría a que 2...
a que 2
es exactamente lo mismo
que "a" cuadrada...
que "a" cuadrada
entre "b" cuadrada...
entre "b" cuadrada
y lo único que estoy haciendo
es elevar al cuadrado ambos lados de esta igualdad,
elevo al cuadrado la raíz de 2
y el cuadrado con la raíz se va
y aquí me queda "a" entre "b" cuadrada
o dicho de otra manera,
esto es exactamente lo mismo...
esto es exactamente lo mismo
que poner que 2,
2 por "b" cuadrada...
y bueno, estoy suponiendo que
"b" es distinto de 0,
esto es exactamente igual...
esto es exactamente igual
que "a" cuadrada...
que "a" cuadrada,
lo único que hice fue multiplicar
esta igualdad de ambos lados por "b" cuadrada,
de tal manera que aquí se va a cancelar
y solamente me queda "a" cuadrada,
mientras que del lado izquierdo
me queda 2 veces "b" cuadrada,
ok,
¿qué quiere decir esto?
Bueno, pues lo que quiero que veas
es que aquí podemos concluir...
y vamos a ponerlo así...
aquí podemos concluir que "a" cuadrada
debe de ser un número par,
tanto "a" como "b"
son enteros,
precisamente de aquí
nos tomamos una fracción,
que es una división de enteros
y aquí yo tengo 2 por un número entero...
2 por un número entero,
esto me da un número par,
por lo tanto cuando
yo tengo un número entero
y lo multiplico por 2,
es un número
par
que es el valor de "a" cuadrada
y entonces
puedo decir que "a" cuadrada
es
par...
es par.
Muy bien, ¿y esto para qué nos sirve?
Bueno porque si "a" cuadrada es par
y es que quiero que recuerdes,
"a" cuadrada es lo mismo
que decir "a" por "a",
"a" por "a" entonces
es
par, es par.
¿Y esto para qué?
Porque quiero que recuerdes un poco algo
de lo que hemos visto,
si yo tengo por ejemplo
un número par,
a un número par lo multiplico
por un número par,
bueno, pues esto sabemos
que nos da un número par...
un número par,
2 por 2 es 4, 8 por 8 es 64
y si yo tengo un número impar...
un número impar
y a éste lo multiplico por
un número impar...
lo multiplico por un número impar obtengo
obtengo un número impar,
¿eso que quiere decir?
bueno que si par por par,
nos da un número par,
entonces "a" por "a"
nos da un número par
y esto, esto quiere decir
que "a", "a" es par...
es par.
La única manera
de que tengamos un número
multiplicado por sí mismo
que nos dé un número par,
debe de ser que ese número sea par
o dicho de otra manera,
podemos decir...
y déjame cambiar de color para que lo veas
con este color...
dicho de otra manera
podemos decir que "a"
lo podemos escribir... lo podemos escribir
como un número par,
es decir como 2 veces
un cierto número "k", ok.
Como "a" es par lo podemos
ver como dos veces "k"
porque este de aquí es un número par,
ok.
Y bueno, ¿para qué todo esto?
Porque cuando nosotros decimos
que "a" es un número par
y lo podemos representar aquí,
ahora voy a utilizar
esta información para
sustituir a "a" aquí
y llegar a que "b" también
es un número par,
piénsalo un segundo
por ahí va la clave para llegar a la contradicción,
si nosotros vemos
que "b" es un número par,
entonces estamos
llegando a una contradicción
de que esta fracción sea irreducible
y tras eso vamos.
Ok, como "a"
lo podemos ver como "2k",
¿qué te parece si lo sustituimos
justo en esta ecuación que tengo aquí?
Y me va a quedar que dos veces "b"...
lo voy a poner aquí, dos veces "b"...
"b" cuadrada,
dos veces "b" cuadrada...
esto es exactamente lo mismo...
estoy escribiendo esta ecuación aquí...
que "a" cuadrada.
Pero "a" lo podemos ver como "2k"
y esto elevado al cuadrado,
es decir, esto es lo mismo que "2k"
elevado al cuadrado,
lo que representa
"a" cuadrada,
solamente estoy sustituyendo
en esta ecuación.
Y bueno, de aquí podré obtener
que dos veces "b",
dos veces "b" cuadrada ,
es exactamente lo mismo
y aquí voy a elevar al cuadrado
y me queda 4 veces "k" cuadrada,
4 veces "k" cuadrada
o dicho de otra manera,
si divido todo entre 2 voy a llegar a que...
éste es el color de "b"...
el color de "b",
"b" cuadrada es exactamente
lo mismo que dos veces "k" cuadrada...
que dos veces "k" cuadrada,
lo único que hice fue dividir
esta parte entre 2
y esta parte también
la dividí entre 2
y justo estoy llegando a que
"b" cuadrada es igual a "2k" cuadrada,
lo que quiere decir por el mismo razonamiento ,
un razonamiento muy análogo
que "b" cuadrada...
aquí estoy diciendo que "b" cuadrada
debe de ser un número par,
"b" cuadrada es par
porque
lo puedo representar
como dos veces
un cierto número
y si "b" cuadrada es par,
ok, de aquí puedo obtener
que "b" debe de ser par,
"b" es par por el mismo razonamiento
de acá arriba,
par por par me debe de dar un número par
y si "b" cuadrada es par,
forzosamente
"b" debe de ser par, ok,
de aquí me fui para acá
y de aquí me fui para acá
y entonces estoy diciendo
que "b" es un número
que lo puedo ver como...
vamos a escribirlo así...
a "b"...
a "b" lo puedo ver
de la siguiente manera,
dos veces...
dos veces un cierto número "m"
y justo aquí es donde cae la contradicción
y aquí es lo más importante de este video,
si "b" es igual a dos veces "m"
y "a" es igual a dos veces "k",
tienen un factor común
que es 2,
tanto "b" es par
como "a" es par
y justo habíamos dicho que
"a" entre "b" era una fracción irreducible,
si "a" entre "b"
es una fracción irreducible
entonces tanto "a"
como "b",
no tienen ningún factor común,
pero acabamos de encontrar
que si tienen factor común y...
¡Oh no!
aquí está lo malo del asunto,
esto es una contradicción,
acabo de llegar a algo que no se puede
porque habíamos supuesto
justo lo contrario,
ésta es una contradicción,
lo que me está diciendo
que entonces raíz de 2
no puede ser racional,
porque justo de
aquí partimos
y si raíz de 2 no puede ser racional,
estoy diciendo
que ya llegamos a
nuestro resultado.
Estoy diciendo que raíz de 2 es irracional,
nosotros empezamos diciendo
que raíz de 2 es racional,
entonces lo podemos ver como "a" entre "b",
una fracción irreducible
y esto quiere decir que "a" y "b"
no tienen ningún factor común excepto el 1
y llegamos al "a" y "b"
tienen como factor común al 2
y entonces aquí
se da la contradicción
y en ese momento podemos concluir entonces
que raíz de 2 debe de ser irracional.